okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about a specific design
uh
thing which is themes for graphs
and
i think i was not even aware so let me
show some things
um
that are
sort of typical
themed
um
let's just get an example here
this one
okay
how would i approximate that
with existing plot themes
so let's say for example i make a random
graph
um
okay now i want to say make that graph
with plot theme
arrow
okay well this is these are stupid names
business is not a web are just not the
right kinds of names for these
it's just this is the wrong what what is
this this is not the right kind of
naming
okay these are the same 80s that's the
same thing that works across the whole
system i know but the autocomplete here
if there are special things for graphs
the autocomplete should be covering
those
am i making sounds good go back to the
autocomplete
and maybe you want them to be first by
the way
they're the bottom there i think
hit the arrow at the very bottom
you already lost the game yeah you lost
the game big time
okay i don't even see them here
if you go back there is classic labeled
you know index labeled and such
okay
okay
look
okay
let's start off
i
mean you know we've developed for the
physics project we've developed a decent
number
of
well okay
so another issue is
these styles have to have both
i mean the
this is presumably a vertex shape
function
is that right that's generating this
thing here is that right or is it
something different from that
well if i remember the code it was a
vertex shaped function
and insert of panel of some
crazy structure
okay but crazy structures aren't what
we're looking for here
um
so i mean the question is why do you say
it's crazy
oh well it was more in terms of the
implementation i mean it's just the
the same has the
classic label there it's busy more
pretty much a
rectangle with this size
so let's do the following let's say
graph of this
and then let's say plot theme
arrow
classic labeled
what what did that do now
yeah go ahead
well so essentially you know
it um
in terms of precedence right so if the
resource function have you know vertex
shape and styling preset so we preserve
that
and then the plot team just modified
what it can't so in this case it
i think it's just the
vertex or the h style and the vertex
style which was modified
but it presents unfortunately we kind of
have the wrong people in this meeting
because we didn't have the people who
were supposed to be here
which i'm kind of annoyed about
um
and
look
okay first point is these are
badly named
badly presented
and maybe they will do and i mean you
know classic labeled is just freaking
ugly
how do i get something which is not ugly
labelled
so first classic level is to preserve
you know the classic name what was in
version six that's why we kept it
so if you want to look as in version 6
you get it okay okay fine i don't care
about that i care about having something
where look
let's get um
okay so now i want to take that graph
and i want to make that give me how do i
make that something which looks a decent
approximation to this
what do i type here
so you put classic label on no no no no
no you lost the game that's ugly we
didn't revise those styles in a decade
how do i get something which has
labeled nodes that is decently styled
right now it's classic label that's no
good
that's no good
because we didn't redo that design for a
decade and it looks really ugly and by
the way it didn't even work
no no we did this so
what i want to point out that
this design was to preserve the look but
we did it so we cannot improve it if
that's the case
but this didn't work
okay you lost the game here what
happened
because he's not taking into account the
size of the label yeah but why not
it's possibly get more complicated but
it's possible yes
so
what we need to do here
the first thing we need to do
is presumably
something that says
you know plot three arrow labeled
okay and then we've got the sub cases of
name labeled and index labeled
am i making sense
okay but i don't even know that's right
because i mean i think it's it's it's
some
i mean maybe it's called vertex labeled
or something because we've got two cases
we've got the case
where
um
yeah i mean we've also got this thing
sandra is pointing out on our live
stream the issue is
um
that you know if we do labeling so let's
say that we did graph
okay that's fairly ugly right it could
place these labels
so that they're not colliding with the
edges
how come we're not doing that
is
you know we are working on that we are
progressively improving level placement
you know in 12 we made already some
change and improved that so we are still
working on those
okay so this is something you think you
can solve
um yes definitely
but now
i mean
i'm not okay so so look
there are different cases we want first
thing is vertex labeled that is
make
the vertices contain their labels
and maybe that's not the right name for
that but that you understand what i'm
saying
right you want the box yes you want the
box which contain the labels
right which by the way i just want to
point out is not always possible right
in
in the most decent case i mean i can
generate a string which is longer than
the
this you know the size of the the
graphic or the page of well then it will
fail
but i mean that's a typical thing
now
you know another case
that is pretty common
is let me show you another one of these
um
i mean
and again i don't know how common
each of these cases is but this is
another fairly common case where there
are two kinds of nodes
right
now one of the things that happens
i'm trying to understand here because
basically if i say vertex shape function
i mean
how would you do this
these nodes i think they have names if i
look at the
vertex list here
yeah there's two kind those are the
different names you see what i'm saying
right
so for the case where it's an integer
you write a pattern and then you map it
to
the first vertex shape function and when
is the list
we generate a circle which is
yellow
yeah i i know but but so let's let's
actually do this so
let's get edge list of this
so we just have those
and now we'll say graph
and then we'll say this
and then we'll say vertex
what do we say
tell me what to say
actually if you can see the text shape
function
yep
and then we can define it
okay so here's another thing these these
autocompletes for the vertex shape
function
they need things which correspond to
things like this you see what i'm saying
because the vertex shape function knows
it has a standardized function right
we could have a named function
that does
the
yes right i think vertex shape forms can
it take patterns charles yeah it does
pattern yeah so you could have you know
like underscore integer
ghost i like that very much but the
question is what does it go to
and what you had in mind here was just
these static things what i'm saying is
no you can have a function there
i know that but i want a standardized
function that just puts
the name in a box type thing you get
what i'm saying
right so you want that shape function
would define this
in instead of a circle you want that
square box exactly i want but i want
something that has content i don't just
want look here let's try it okay
underscore integer arrow
diamond i don't know why that's okay
underscore and then underscore list goes
to
um
i don't know
i don't know what you had there circle
didn't work
oh no maybe it did those are diamonds
there so let's try what was another name
here was another name for that
capsule i think was a name you
had and then you can also save vertex
label integer goes to
name and then you will put it integer on
it
so we just need to module that in one
plotting
okay
okay but but let's let's look at what we
need here so first of all
we need a named vertex shape function
that isn't just a diamond it's something
that puts the name there because that's
something you can do from a vertex shape
function
do you understand what i'm saying
um yes
okay
so
right now if we look at vertex shape
function
the named vertex shape functions
where are the name vertex shape
functions
where are they
so right now you access them by doing
graph element data that's horrifying
that's horrifying
i
really hate that design i mean th this
look this micro discovery business
i just don't think we're doing it the
right way i don't think this is how it
should work
i think perhaps we should use the data
repository i mean that you know the
classic example of micro discovery is
musical instruments for sound note
did you understand what i'm
saying yes
roger maybe you have comments about this
yeah we need we needed a mechanism and i
know so i'm saying but i don't think we
have musical instruments
we don't have one there we don't have
one we have many i think that's even
worse because that's just written on a
page
yes i know it's it is this is
programmatic
roger it is worse
okay so so i'm all open we we need to
find such things
okay so let's talk about what that
should be so one of the things we did
for charting is we built a whole palette
where you can actually explore
with parameters i know i know i know it
also has one of these functions that you
can program you can both
programmatically and visually
and experimentally discover them
second here
okay
so that's a mechanism
similar to in product browsing of a
repository right it's another one of
these
you know
discovery type mechanisms am i making
sense
and
you know
the mechanisms that we have for this
are
well you know we have had the pallets
mechanism which i don't like very much
we have had
the um
you know what are the mechanisms so
we're talking here about
um by the way
we don't have any project management
person here do we
i'm here avery okay okay good
um
okay
so micro discovery
mechanisms i mean one thing we have is
functions like graph element data
another thing we have is functions like
net model
connecting to a repository backed by a
repository
what other mechanisms do we have
auto completion
yeah
okay what are the mechanisms
uh documentation
is another one
okay and what other ones
i think documentation is the main one
okay
all right
so
a potential one
is data repository
and for example
i mean another one
i suppose is a sort of pseudo one is
wolfram language data
i mean one thing that's good about the
repository like it is themes okay
there's been the intent since the very
beginning that that would be user
extensible
you know that one can contribute and
share
so that is kind of set up for that
there's a lot of other things that are
you know maybe not as equally
but it's it's it's hard to imagine a
whole repository for it
um
sorry sorry so
well we're making a repository now for
color palettes right
yep
no i mean you know
it's not obvious
the whole idea of this of resource
system is that it should be somewhat
lightweight
so that we should be able to have micro
repositories
okay am i making sense
yes no
wrong people here what's the story
my intake is that even lightweight
repositories are heavy
well is there i mean yes it's just the
way you know if
if it's easy to set up and build
that's the current issue now i had a
couple of discussions with bob about you
know all that too so it's the whole
process of being able to set that open
right well the question is i mean to me
something like this list
could be in a data repository entry and
we could simply point from the
documentation to the data repository
entry
is it significantly better than the
graph element data yes it is because
that's just a mess
at least
we've got some whole mechanism
where i mean this is like 7 000
different mechanisms for this we've
either got to have
a standardized way of doing this for all
these different you know like musical
instruments what are we going to do call
it musical instrument data like that i
mean i don't know what what you know
or oh the other place we've got is the
entity system
right it's control equal and
well we've got the entity system as in
these could be entities
and then we've got the idea of entity
list and so on
which again i don't consider to be
particularly
strong discovery you know discovery
mechanism
making sense i mean for the longest time
we all complained that there was no way
of discovering entities and now we've
sort of have some kind of documentation
it's not the strongest documentation but
it's
it it does give you a way to discover
things
look the
once you're using yes i i agree i think
but i don't think
i think entities
are
you know
clearly we can say entity list
of well geometric scene there's an
obscure one
and you know i use this with some
frequency if i want to find
you know how do i get the entity first
thing here okay that's how i do it but i
don't consider this to be
you know
this isn't i mean i i bet there's an
entity type for
um
okay let's see how would i get parts of
speech for example
let's see what happens if i say control
equals
noun
grammatical unit okay now this is this
is less than wonderful in terms of
okay
so if i say input form of that i can say
entity list of grammatical unit
and then i'll get a bunch of things here
are making sense
this is what would have happened if you
just said control equal parts of speech
i don't know that's a good question
yeah that's a bug i mean that that's
something that should work
see i think that doesn't work because in
in wolfen alpha that wouldn't make a lot
of sense but i think and avery that's
something for you to
to note for people okay that the
discovery of of entity lists is
important
uh so i mean i don't consider this a
stellar example
i do think that in a case like this
that if it said
this
you know resource data of blah blah blah
gives
the named vertex functions i think that
will be a perfectly adequate thing
by making sense and that will be very
lightweight and doesn't require that we
have a thing you know graph element data
which by the way isn't a link here i
don't even know why not
what is it so you can copy and paste it
out easily without
well that's a bad click to copy
no it's because it's not documented
yeah
because you didn't want to document it
well okay fair enough but so we've got
to fail here i mean this this is so look
i think
that the best place to start with this
is in the data repository
does anybody object to that
i i would say that for the number of
things that we're talking about there
at present that the best thing is just
you know something directly in the docs
no that's a fail i am fed up with
scraping documentation to get the list
of possible musical instruments for
sound note no we're not doing it
okay the the now we can say here in the
documentation we could list these things
in the documentation but we should say
this is available
in this data
repository entry you get what i'm saying
right i think i see what you're saying i
mean i still find value in you know so
like
was it hat shading
has you know okay let's put the table
with the 20 things in it look
let's look oh sorry hatch filling sorry
well even that one that you know we
discussed at the time and
i think
even that one at the time we decided to
actually build a repository just that we
haven't yet got there
right but the beginning
okay so the beginning of this would be
you present this and you say
uh possible pattern fillings include and
then you just say you just put these in
a data repository entry and you just
give a link to it here
do you get what i'm saying
do you understand what i'm saying
you're saying instead of this array or
no in addition yeah if we feel like
putting the array here great
magnificent
okay but if we're not going to bother to
put the array then we just list
you know
i mean
when you say putting it in a resource in
you say you say
the resource repository but it's uh
there's no no i'm sorry i'm sorry i said
the data repository
i said
i said the data repository here right
the data repository
and that will come up with a list so you
can programmatically you would have a
data set in the data set repository that
contained all the things right it would
just be this would be there would be
a
a thing in the data repository that is
that list there there will be a thing in
the data repository that is the list of
maybe it's a data set in some cases
by default or maybe it's just a list
maybe that's all it is
it's just that list that piece of data
that's it that's everything that's there
am i making sense
roger you understand
yeah
it doesn't sound easier
it's much easier
and we're gonna and it will get
documented because then it has a page in
the data repository that just says this
is a list of possible vertex shape
functions
that's it it's very simple page
okay
okay but i mean we need a mechanism so
if this isn't the mechanism we need a
different mechanism but we need a
mechanism a uniform mechanism that is
for micro discovery of these kinds of
lists am i making sense
so i mean this may be the wrong group to
talk about this although i think it's
not a terrible group but you know we
need okay so there are really two
choices as far as i'm concerned
the
maybe three choices okay
uh i mean okay so a piece we don't have
here
is um
uh well a complete repository new
repositories
new repositories
uh plus
in product browsing
am i making sense
do you understand what i'm saying yes
okay
so i think you know
uh
current
micro discovery
methods
okay so one possibility
is
everything in data repository
okay
another possibility is
a single new symbol
i mean
okay so
another thing would be
a new repository
uh with an accessor symbol
like net model you understand what i'm
saying there
i mean i don't think that one is is
obviously terrible i mean
you know and and that repository will be
essentially a
uh well it'd be like well from language
data but it wouldn't be called that it
would become something like um
what would it be called what would we
call this helper data
um
[Music]
do you understand what i'm saying what
would what would you say
to get
something like this or the list of
musical instruments or the possible
filling patterns
what would you say is data or argument
data or
settings data isn't terrible
that's actually not bad at all i think
so then we call it settings data of
let's say vertex shape function
and it could even be
something like this
i mean this could be the place where we
hang
sort of things like default values of
options and stuff like this
do you see what i'm saying
i'm just trying to think
so
the things that that that may need more
than one symbol to characterize so chart
layout for instance
okay it depends on which function you're
in
okay fine
all right so then then i mean layout
yeah
okay so then it's something like you
know plot 3d arrow plot layout or
something
maybe or plot
plot range would be
you know the 2d versus 3d things versus
yeah well so i mean that's one
possibility that an alternative would be
settings data
of
you know plot 3d
plot layout
i don't know what the best i don't know
what the best way to to characterize it
is but it seems to me
this is
this is a um okay let me mention another
another mechanism
is wfr functions
okay so let me give you an example of
that
there is one called
um
that one there
okay so this is
a oops this is a giant list you see what
this is
this is essentially exactly that
settings data
do you get what i'm saying
i see so the the the the top level is
the type where it applies
level that's correct yeah that's correct
and then there was like a big set of
options underneath each one
right so right exactly so if i say if i
get the top level here and i ask for
keys
i'll get the various different kinds of
graphs
those sort of different graphs that you
guys use
right and other things i don't know what
set replace type is that's an
interesting one so i mean in a sense
this is a prototype
of settings data
i don't know exactly what that's doing
there but but um
uh
but you know yeah these are basically
default i don't know what north rule is
but but but we're talking about the
discoveries you want to know what the
set possible settings are these are
specific settings
these are specific settings right so we
talked about possible settings right but
so so this thing with vertex shape
function
should return
presumably these
as i mean
you know or in this case here
i'm sure that they are the same for 2d
and 3d
no okay fine but i mean but i'm saying
whatever whatever it is okay so but what
i'm saying is there's the names and then
there's what they are and both will be
useful to have
you see what i'm saying
what do you mean by what they are
well i mean in this case the
checkerboard what the actual data that
represents that checkerboard is
see in this case what we're seeing is
look in in this case what i'm doing here
if i take this thing
and i say
actually this is kind of interesting to
see that
you see what i'm saying
this is a bunch of settings
of things and these are the sub settings
within each one
and
i would say just being able to access i
mean here we've got a function that's
doing this
but from settings data
being able to access the complete i mean
you know
something like
if you say give me the settings data for
this particular thing maybe what i get
back for vertice function
is exactly something like this a data
set that says in its first key plot 3d
is this blah blah blah
so i'm saying so settings data of that
alone would be the complete information
on settings for that symbol
you see what i'm saying
and if i say something like this
if i say settings data of that comma
plot 3d
then i would get the specific one for
the graph 3d whatever then i would get
the specific one for that
in other words what it is is it's a
combination human and machine discovery
thing if i do this i'll get a data set i
can see as a human roughly what's there
but i'm going to put it in a program i
mean in programs that i write all the
time i've got things that say
resource function well from physics
project style data branch or graph edge
style
see what i'm saying
and um
or here notice this this is useful
this is something which will take a
function so for example take a graph so
if i do this
and i say
over there
um
and i say this thing here
of function
of
percent 189
that will restyle that as a branch of
graph see what i'm saying
you get it what it's doing
did you understand
but
roger do you understand or not i think i
understand but but we have already
mechanisms that do that
no no but but but what do you mean we
have mechanisms to do that
for graphics you know or
sure sure sure sure sure but this is
saying
from the discovery
of like let's say
this is a bad example here this this is
an example where we have yeah this is a
certain style of graph right and it uses
this graph there if you look at the
function of course it does of course it
uses graph right but what i'm saying is
if
the issue is
okay this is maybe a small point about
this what we actually are discovering so
to speak
do you get what i'm saying but
okay so first point here look i really
like this idea of settings data i think
this is a good idea and this is a good
place to put all this stuff and that
would go into you know it it will
probably be backed it should be backed
by a repository
stephen define it this level how do you
get like you're basically you know in
your physics stuff defining themes for a
given
function
yes is function so how do you get that
theme out of this because you're you're
attacking it the other way
with settings data
right there's no sense of a theme it's
individual options to
sub well
i'm saying that what we would do is we
would say settings data
of graph no of of well let's see how do
we do it
because that specific orientation or
group of themes of settings together is
really what you want in the physics case
i know i know i know but that's a plot
theme basically i mean this is
essentially
settings data
of
plot theme for a graph
and right now those named plot themes
are found in documentation not
particularly well documented
um and the idea here potentially would
be
uh that both this would find it
programmatically
and
that the typical thing would be that
something like this well plot theme of
graph there would return a data set
okay and then what we would be able to
do if you said of
uh i don't know you know vertex labeled
for example then that would actually
return
the settings data
for that plot theme vertex labeled you
get what i'm saying so it will be
equivalent to say this will be
equivalent
saying
plot theme
arrow this
would be equivalent to saying plot theme
arrow vertex labeled
does that make sense
roger yeah
no okay
i mean but we were talking about
discovering the names but oh i see you
want this sort of the detailed the sort
of absolute kind of like absolute
options type yeah i mean what i'm
suggesting is that it will be useful to
have
in in cases like this why not have the
actual data for this available
because that way we don't have to have
nailed it completely
that you know that we got the precise
right but i mean it doesn't really
matter the main point is that things
like this will be useful because that
way you can mix and match things you
could say
uh you know a vertex label like for
example here let's say we had this
and then we drilled down and we said
edge
edge style or something
yes that makes sense but you know under
the assumption that
you know your plot team are defined by
those you know options which are
documented or up to that level there is
a certain level of complexity even for
graph where
you cannot just build those you know
describe the plot team just based on the
style or the option we have
i'm sorry what
you're saying that that for graph plot
theme is going in and using internal
things not accessible to the user is
that correct
right or there is some more white or
some other state which are more
necessary than just you know external
vertex style vectorship functions
okay and what are those things
and why aren't they accessible to the
user
well i don't remember on top of my mind
okay well let's find out what they are
let's find out what they are and then
perhaps what we need
if they are sort of tweaking
maybe we need a a a catch-all
option to these functions that says
something like plot tweaking arrow
and then it's a big association you see
what i'm saying
it's because it's basically method
it is more or less
but or tweaking arrow
and then it's an association
it's not quite method but but it's it's
uh
you know
or it's something like you know detail
um i don't know it's not quite detailed
options i don't know exactly what it's
called but you get what i'm saying
and i don't think that would be a bad
i agree and i think it might be a more
structured version of some aspects of
method as well
i making sense
yeah i mean in terms of of the viz
functions it is method it's
and and the number one set of things
that we use
undocumented functionality for is
to specify a default so that you know if
somebody says
plot with some theme and they set plot
style that the plot style combines with
the theme instead of overwriting it
okay
um
ethan is commenting on a live stream the
solution for exploring graph styling
would be to enhance the attached cell
not a bad point i don't think that's the
only place to put it i agree that's
another that is a good that should be in
our list
of things of of ways to do this
is the attached cell
and before the attached cell we had to
right click
sub menu
in the suggestions bar
[Music]
okay
i think the correct future solution is
the attach cell i think that previous
solutions the the local menu
and the suggestions bar didn't work out
yeah
i mean the attached cell doesn't work as
well as i might like either i mean like
for image 3d and things like that where
an attached cell is very it's a nice
well done attached cell
but i find myself really wanting to do
stuff programmatically
i'm making sense i don't know why but
but i don't same issues with the
suggestions bar
that i kind of don't trust it and i
would prefer to just do it
programmatically
i don't know what other people's feeling
about that is
i think our attached cells have become
better
the the image 3d one is very old
um
and so i think we're slowly learning
better ways of doing it like
but it's a way to get exposure and
discovery so for instance if you do a
mesh region that attached cell is just
pretty nice
can be better and it will grow you know
over time but it's pretty nice you'd
probably discover things you didn't even
know right
well okay fair enough but okay so let's
loop back here and then we should
wrap up fairly soon here um i think the
settings data thing is a really good
idea and i think we should have a
probably a separate meeting with the
right people next time
really emphasizing that point
to really go through and figure out
what needs to be in there which
functions
could
feed ancillary tables and i and i had
asked some time ago the documentation
team to find all of these random
ancillary tables and documentation
are making sense avery that's something
you should chase
yep i can chase that
the
okay so then
um
i mean this would also solve the problem
of where to hang
things like default values for options
which we've never had a good place to
hang we've never had a programmatic
place to put those people have asked for
those for years now this won't be
perfect because many of those things
aren't straightforwardly programmatic
but that's a start now let's come back
to the original thing about plots
okay so first thing is the first action
item is clearly the vertex shape
function needs some settings that should
be correctly exposed in autocomplete
that are essentially function settings
am i making sense
charles do you understand what i'm
saying
yes
okay
and so
if you if if if you could propose some
potential designs i would recommend you
ask the people who should have been in
this meeting which include the people
who've worked on all these functions
people like nick for example
um
other people
uh who've been involved in these
functions who are the people who should
have been here
well we didn't know that it was a you
know physic project no it's not
particularly but it you know
somebody should have asked the question
i don't know why they didn't
anyway whatever a mistake but we'll not
make that mistake again
um
the
okay
we got background noise here please cut
it out
um
okay
so
we know we need this we i don't know
whether we have things
for labeling edges well and so on
we we know we need
okay so
do you think you have an understanding
of what's needed in terms of i mean
these plot themes are not useful
especially not with the names they have
right now so that's a separate thing is
going through the plot themes and fixing
those but the most obvious thing is to
make vertex shape function be able to
deal with having actual labels at every
node so so i mean for example
you know common things we'll need are
things like
uh you know a circular
uh
a circular
uh
you know
the thing that's equivalent to placed
center
for a vertex label do you understand
what i'm saying
yes
okay that's one case we need that case
we need the rectangular case where we're
dealing with things which are long
labels like this
okay
so so let me just be careful so you want
some name for the text label and the
texture function
yeah i want i want names
that are i want names that capture
the common cases right
right but
like in this example where you have you
know a label
and you want the vertex shape function
to take into account the label size
right normally it doesn't go into vector
shape function but you want us to also
include that so we include a case like
that which
is vertex shape function which is
actually
interacting with vertex label or any
other i'm not sure about that i mean i i
think it would be nice i think it would
be pleasant for users if vertex label
could have a setting that does something
with vertex labels
do you get what i'm saying
i think that would be pleasant i think
it will be user friendly
i think we could do it user unfriendly
yeah we got three different options then
we've got plot theme we've got vertex
label and we've got vertex shape
function and those go in in
you know increasing order of specificity
right
yes
okay so
what
do we want to do okay so so again let's
we say plot theme
vertex label
and vertex shape function
i mean
i think we should support this at all
three levels
i think a named vertex labels
um
would be
a very nice thing to have
it is vertex labels plural right i
always use the autocomplete yes
i mean we just we already have names one
we just need to extend that collection
yes i know i know so let's make a list
here
so down here we're going to make a list
of some of the things we know we need
okay um
so
for
vertex labels
among the things we know we need well
here
um
okay we need
uh
i mean i don't know what their name
their names should be but circular
and by the way these colors are just
terrible and we need to fix these
okay
i mean and um
i think we need the
th that should be there but there needs
to be other ones i agree with you yeah
no good
that is what classic label would do but
we want labeled which is a properly
designed modern version
exactly that's what i'm saying yeah
right i don't know why we never got that
okay we had a name label and next index
label you actually had asked them and
they implemented to review them
there is name labeled
an index label
okay i don't think they're very
beautiful but they're okay
okay so look this is circular labels
which is similar to name labeled
but that's
now we also need
uh
i don't know what we call it text labels
or something which is you know
uh
rectangular boxes so to speak you know
what i'm
saying
because if i did this here
if i said i don't know how to do this
how would i do this how would i make
these long labels well let's just do
this one here let's do this this graph
here
whatever
not what we want
right you understand that's not what we
want
i mean to me
name labeled doesn't say
you know it means you know we have the
capability we know we have the
capability look at this example up here
we know we have the capability to do
this let's stephen can you do that
example from the edge list
which i mean still is wrong but i think
it's different
i mean
you just want the label to be in the
middle and circle
i don't want to circle in the case of
these long ones
okay
yeah i mean look look we want something
where the edges where the
you know
i'm trying to think about the cases that
we've encountered okay so so let me let
me mention some cases i've encountered
okay so we've got circular labels
we've got text labels which are
rectangular boxes we've got
uh essentially coloring
for labels
that is if they're a small number of
different
categories i want to use colors to
distinguish the colors for
for um
okay so small number
of distinct
node types
actually actually i mean there's there's
a different
um
um
you see what i'm saying here i mean in
other words in
and i don't know how these are tagged
exactly because obviously if the node
had the same name it would be the same
node
it's gonna say that's the tricky part
i know what you're thinking and
yeah well i mean i've i've seen this
many times where it's a pattern
basically
but in a sense we have that we have
vertex style arrow whatever
with patterns
by the way there should be more examples
in documentation a lot of this
documentation is quite thin there should
be more examples with patterns and so on
and also please please and this is roger
this is for you you know we have
examples i've looked at these examples
we have examples where three things are
going on in one example
we really have got to cut those out
am i making sense
roger are you here
i'm sorry i had to deal with a thing
here at the house just could you repeat
the last thing what was this here
i'm saying there are inadequate examples
for a lot of these i mean let's take
vertex labels for example
okay
you see this is just wrong it's just
wrong
the first example here should be vertex
labels arrow automatic not this example
okay shall i modify the documentation
right now to do that because that's the
first example that should be here
right yes
yes we will do a pass on the
documentation this documentation is
version 10. we had added vertex
automatic we need to spend time and
results to update the whole
documentation so
right but i mean this is this is like
completely
i mean why are you showing this i don't
give a damn about that that's a cool
feature but i don't give a damn and this
is i don't understand this this is not
use this is not what you should do you
should evaluate that
look this is like this is a
quintessential example no this is wrong
as well it should be v1 v2 v3
not
one arrow whatever you get what i'm
saying it should show that case you can
say vertex labels arrow and then the
list of vertex names you get what i'm
saying
not multiple things going on with the
table there
am i making sense
yes
okay so let's let's go through and get
these fixed if you want
i mean
i use these functions all the time i
could probably write this documentation
if you really can't get it done i'll do
it i do you're not very good at
documentation stephen your documentation
examples
are often without any comments
whatsoever we will fix this that's a
really big problem
where do
you don't even know what you're supposed
to learn from your examples
where's an example of that example
zillions of them
particularly in the core language part
i'm very surprised by you saying that
because i don't recall any example of
that you often do examples without any
comment zero comment all right
they should have comments
just this it doesn't work
right these are inadequate
so let's get them fixed and let's get
this tracked so we actually make sure it
is fixed
i mean i i can tell you that as an
actual user of this i have simply been
unable to find things here
and i'm like why are you showing me the
same
you know whatever
okay let's go back over here
we've got various vertex label types
we've probably got
i'm i'm less familiar with with the edge
labeling
okay do we have a way of doing edge
labeling along the along the edge we do
so you have a coordinate system for the
edge
no i understand that coordinate system
okay but if the edge is is curved for
example how how would i get
um there's a zero one coordinate system
that's relative along the edge okay does
it does it curve the the text when it
when it goes on it does not no we do not
i mean we could have been able to
orientate no i understand i'm just off
does it orient the the label along the
edge orientation or not
no
i see so it's just plopping it somewhere
yes okay well that's something
but
i mean again
i again i don't know what the
what the label types
you know
what the named things should be
um
but look i mean this is the hierarchy
and i'm happy you know if the right
people have been in this meeting they
probably would have been able to tell
you a whole bunch of things that i'm
sort of just trying to
think of here that are the obvious
things we need for what the settings
should be for these
i mean i've given you a few here
but you know
look the general comment is we're so
close to having a system that's really
good here
but we just fall down on the fact that
even i can't use it
am i making sense
even i don't know how to use it
that's not a good sign
make sense
okay
nobody's saying anything well
uh what is the status of collision
avoidance for labels
um
the
probably the stuff that jose has worked
on most recently
well jose shouldn't be the person
working on that well no but i mean he he
did it for the geo stuff
um
what is your plan for vertex label
collision avoidance
or label collision avoidance in general
is the question for breto for me
it's a question in general
um i mean i think we need to get
somebody else to work better
no so
if we have a plan for doing it or do we
not have a plan for doing it yes
we do have a plan and it needs to be
a similar system that we build for
visualization and then jo and we need to
build
or use reuse if we can yes similar
system for graphs but there have been
other things that have been brought up
because we have graph layout algorithms
to some extent can probably help to
solve the same problems
okay but years ago
like i think tom implemented a bunch of
stuff for contour label avoidance that
doesn't work we're gonna have to redo
that
okay
well so which cases do we have this we
have contour label we have geo labels we
have graph labels we have plot
so the plot labels
are pretty extensive
uh you know
and the gao is starting to be also
extensive
right but you you i know you've done
stuff for plot labels and it isn't bad
right yeah i mean you believe in that
you believe in the collusion avoidance
that you have to plot labels is that
true
yes yeah
i mean of course it will break down at
some point but yeah right right
i consider it decently good except for
the mystery from time to time and i've
reported some bugs recently about this
of labels just disappearing for no
particularly good reason in other words
so
so uh here's the history of labels is
that we started
charting was the first area that got
label support
and it's still fixed it's fixed location
labeling it's not adaptive labeling i'm
saying but at least there's coordinate
systems so that's what placed this it's
a relative coordinate system to whatever
you place around so it's like a polar
coordinate systems for pie charts it's a
rectangular one for bar charts etc it's
a linear one for edges and so on
so so that's also a graph was built
graph was built with a fixed placement
label system which meant that that it
wouldn't be sort of necessarily adaptive
we then went in and adapted all the
layouts the fixed um
so and the um
and the parametric graphs you know like
complete graphs and circle there's often
you know
fixed but optimal to that particular
layout those are done so those are
usually come out pretty nice now the
general purpose graph1 needs to do what
we then went on to build for plot labels
which is basically optimization based
collision avoidance and we've since
built also for
heard geo
yeah we haven't done this project yet
for graphs okay fine but but what what
you're communicating there is that you
basically know what to do it just isn't
done yet yes
and so is it using our actual
optimization
technology or no
no so so and often you need to do
something that's
that's
um
no it's not it's it's using
something custom written for this case
you know so something called taboo
search in the case of plot labels
and
in the case of
geo i think it's just basically
combinatorial elimination but super fast
so
so i have a question there let's say
that you were trying to make the most
beautiful version of some plot
if we were using our full
you know convex optimization this that
and the other stuff
could we make it more beautiful probably
probably and so the question is how you
abstract i mean so you need
uh um
yes we probably could
you know but but it's not super trivial
to quantify aesthetic goals no i
understand that i understand it's it's
not super trivial but i mean if we
already have effectively done that if we
specified that
in effect for the other search methods
we use right
you know it could be that there is a
better solution that can be got using
our fancy optimization technology and
that we should have a
you know a super quality performance
goal that does that even if it might
take five minutes
to grind away and that nobody would want
it for interactive use but you want to
present the most beautiful version of
this picture you know then grind it that
way
right
i don't know if that makes sense i mean
i'm just saying if you can define
the goals
you know
properly for our fancy optimization
technology
yeah
i mean a lot of this stuff is you know
there are ways to sort of
um
so for instance the line breaking that
we use in our system is optimization
based
okay and there
this guy don knows came up with the
aesthetic goal
he calls it minimizing badness
so he has a badness objective function
here i don't know exactly what i mean
the original version of all that stuff i
wrote like 35 years ago
for output form and right now i'm
talking about the front end the type
settings i i i understand that i
understand that and that literally uses
the same criteria as canoes you know the
bad does okay
i mean
we probably use effectively different
criteria for output form
yes
but i mean clearly you must have used
something there i don't but did you
formulate it explicitly like that or
yes
somewhere in the code i mean i haven't
thought about this in 35 years but
somewhere right yes i mean yes there
were definite criteria i mean
and and so what what you can do for some
unlike that case like where you're going
to do a line break there's there's a
huge number but it's finite
and so can you basically search all of
them globally
sure right and i mean that that is a big
issue global line breaking is an issue
and particularly there are these loops
you get for things where you have built
up fractions versus slashes
and you can flip around between those
two and blah blah blah blah blah yes i
understand and there are i don't think
we ever thought i mean we i think we
probably thought about but at the time
it wasn't really a possible thing
you know the super optimized linebacker
line breaking is done globally it it's
but no i don't know i know dynamic
optimization to minimize yes i know i
know
but
but okay i mean that happens to be more
or less a one-dimensional case yes
whereas this is more or less a
two-dimensional case right
exactly so
yeah i mean look we've got other things
that are a bit like this like the word
cloud optimization yes
which could do with being faster by the
way
yeah so that's part of a class called um
cutting problems
um
uh you know cutting and packing problems
and
that one is also using specialized
techniques it's basically a rasterize
that's how it's it's able to sort of
consider all a lot of possible products
right
um
okay okay
uh
but
we know what to do and we have more than
one way forward we know it needs to be
done it just hasn't been done okay fine
all right so look we've identified
various things there's some low-hanging
fruit
some of this documentation stuff is
low-hanging fruit
the you know the settings data thing
will need another iteration of design
but i think we should be we should get
ready what we can get into that and i
don't know that's probably in the lcc
meeting
series
then we've got these name vertex types
please make proposals for those again i
don't think they're very difficult i
think you know the extremely good news
look we will we'll we'll do a round for
for thirteen one okay sure
so so fine that let me just say
you know the good news here is
you can make wonderful graphs with our
stuff and we've done tons of that works
really well this is one of those icing
on the cake problems
the cake is already made but it isn't
iced so to speak
i mean
the
so let's get that
you know i think um
let's see
i mean
were there any other things that came
out of this meeting that we need to oh
yeah the other thing is let's get some
better graphic design for some of these
uh for the default
plot labels
you know these default labeled graphs
and so on
making sense
and we are going to need better names
for some of these different cases and i
think once we know what more of those
cases are let's come back and get those
those names
but i'd like it if you guys could
propose those
okay
will do
all right sounds good okay thanks a lot
thanks to folks on our live stream by
the way people ethan is commenting about
draggable graphs
coming no
okay good
and actually sandra is making one
comment which is could there be options
that negate other options
you know that's an interesting idea
that we could have a symbol
that means
essentially just like we have inherited
we could have essentially disinherited
or something not quite disinherited but
you know what i mean so what i mean is
ignore the setting
right so this is
um
uh
you know
ignore
setting or something
setting for options
see what i'm saying so in other words
let's say you've got
i mean you know ultimately it's a
horrifying stack type problem
right but
do you get what i'm saying i mean
in in general in general an option like
for graphics could have multiple levels
of of nested settings
how do we feel about the return to
defaults because
well go ahead what were you going to say
brett were you going to say something
here uh it was not i mean i'm
if you could have you know define a plot
theme and say ignore you know one
specific element of it that seems useful
like like you like a plot thing but
don't like the colors or something you
just want to be default well you can
always override those you can override
them but you can't go back to defaults
can you override to its automatic
behavior right right right over so the
issue is
overriding
back to automatic behavior
that's the question
and we could perfectly well have a
symbol just like we have inherited what
would it be called
um
i mean it could be called default
settings
or if automatic work if you could say
i don't think it will work because i
think automatic in too many cases
is
environmentally determined
exactly
um
it would probably
actually help to have you know concrete
ideas of where
this would come in
well i think that this is
this is basically
that's basically what we want we want to
return it to what automatic would have
done
actually it's not always automatic i
mean we're supposed to have designed
things so that automatic is the
automatic setting
you see what i'm saying so that the
default is the automatic setting that's
that's how things should have been
designed but like vertex labels didn't
end up doing that
right the the default is none
well i mean actually to default setting
you know so
now return to factory settings type
thing
he's not suggesting doing it with sub
options like inherited goes to none
i don't get that i don't see how that
helps because
i don't understand that i mean the the
you mean defining the inheritance
by giving a sub option with inherited
that seems
hard to understand
i mean this idea of default settings
seems like it would be both easy to
implement and rather useful i mean on
the other hand if settings is able to
give you the full spec
then you can just use you know delete
cases to
well you just drill into settings
settings data rather if you drill into
settings data then you could get back to
the default
right you know just by deleting whatever
was causing it to not be the default
yes
well that's not bad either
look setting status seems like something
people have asked for this for years
you know just give me a list of the
possible values for this option
this is a good way to put it in
and it you see that the reason we
haven't done that
in many cases is because there are many
complicated dependencies et cetera and
here what we're doing is we're making
something with settings data which is
first and foremost for human consumption
so that if let's say there are multiple
cases we can have those be string named
cases that simply appear
in the
data set
in other words the mission of settings
data is to provide you in principle
the programmatic access to these
settings
but
it doesn't
you know it's not
programmatically defined where the
programmatic access is if that makes
sense
am i making sense am i not making sense
i mean i i think so i mean so like you
know for some chart element function or
something
you know we have named like you know the
stuff we were looking at earlier we have
strings
you know which may be backed by you know
in the case of you know charles's graph
layout stuff or you know some of his
other things
those strings correspond to c
implementations
yeah
and so the string is just the
you know lowest level that we can return
yeah
well okay fair enough fair enough but
that wasn't the point i was making the
point i was making was reason we have
not documented lots of option settings
is because they're not just like one two
three four five they have complicated
you know structures with
you know of of sublists and this and
that and the other see what i'm saying
so there's no there's no structure right
now that represents other than a pattern
a very a rather ugly pattern
that represents what those
you know option structures could be
i mean ultimately they're defined by a
pattern
but that pattern is not particularly
useful to humans
right
so what i'm saying is the parts that are
nameable i mean i don't know i'm just
making the point that we can have things
where there are string names for
uh these
you know pieces of setting space so to
speak
and that's where we can go with that
anyway we should wrap this meeting so
thanks to everybody and uh the next it's
a pity we didn't have quite the right
people here but i think we managed to
get
uh useful things done with the subset
that we had
um so thanks and bye to folks on the
live stream also thank you for your